alright gentlelady from California mr.
chairman I'd like now like to recognize
the gentleman for from Vermont for a
minute and a half the gentleman from
Vermont is recognized for one on one
half minutes I thank the gentlelady for
yielding mr. speaker in one word in one
word this Republican reconciliation bill
can be described as a fraud nothing more
nothing less a fraud what kind of sense
does it make to ask senior citizens to
pay three hundred and twelve dollars a
year more for a weakened Medicare
program while the Republicans give a
fourteen thousand dollar a year tax
break to people making three hundred
thousand dollars a year why should we
ask low-income workers to pay more in
taxes while we cut and do away with
taxes for some of the largest and most
profitable corporations in America why
do we throw 20,000 Vermonters off of
Medicaid low-income disabled people
children senior citizens off of Medicaid
while we retain and not cut 800 billion
dollars in corporate welfare for the
privilege and the wealthy mr. speaker
this Republican proposal is a fraud and
it must be returned to send up let's
defeat it today the gentleman's time has
expired